a lot of fast X zooms by pretty quickly
so if you didn't quite get why Dom and
Han were talking about Los Bandoleros
there is a reason that supercharged fans
of the franchise will definitely
recognize spoilers for fast X ahead fast
X probably shouldn't be your first
experience with the mythology of The
Fast and Furious Universe it's the 10th
main entry in one of the longest running
film franchises of all time and it's
purported to be the first part of the
franchise's swan song as such fast X
digs into some of the more esoteric
corners of its loud and convoluted lore
it refuses to even so much as tap the
brakes to explain jarring plot points
such as why Dominic Toretto has a son
with someone other than Letty Ortiz or
how Giselle yashar survived her apparent
death in Fast and Furious 6. there's not
even an explanation of how they got
Dwayne Johnson to return to the main
franchise as Luke Hobbs after he
referred to diesel as a candy ass and
criticized co-star Tyrese Gibson's album
saying it's the biggest piece of dog
that I have ever heard this really isn't
a film for casual fans of the fast Saga
even Fast and Furious super fans may
find themselves confused by the weight
afforded to Han and Dom's reflective
slogan Los Bandoleros for Life the term
means the bandits in Spanish and it's a
reference to a 2009 short film written
and directed by Diesel released ahead of
the soft reboot Fast and Furious the
fourth film in the series at the time of
that movie's release in 2009 the concept
of selling a sequel as a fresh entry
point to a franchise was a bit harder
for some to wrap their heads around as
the legend goes that included diesel who
was purportedly worried about fans
having enough narrative context from
Fast and Furious alone aside from a
quick cameo in the third film Tokyo
Drift diesel had left the franchise
behind after the first movie the actor
was meant to co-star with Paul Walker in
2 Fast 2 Furious but felt the sequel
script didn't justify its existence
diesel was essentially replaced by
Gibson who took on the role of Brian
O'Connor's criminal counterpart as
demolition derby driver Roman Pierce
producers were only able to get diesel
to return for his cameo in Tokyo Drift
by giving him the rights to The
Chronicles of Riddick franchise audience
reaction to Diesel's return in Tokyo
Drift was apparently so electric that
the studio bosses realized he was the
key to keeping the franchise on the road
so when diesel expressed concerns that
the soft reboot wouldn't work on its own
they gave him free reign to make a
Prelude that would support the story to
his satisfaction to Diesel's credit Los
Bandoleros actually does address some
fundamental questions that would
otherwise go unanswered in Fast and
Furious the short marks the first
appearance of Tego Calderon and Don Omar
as Tego Leo Enrico Santos two brand new
members of Dom's crew who play key roles
in the features opening oil truck heist
they'd go on to become recurring
characters through the remainder of the
franchise the motivation behind the
heist itself is also explained giving
the job a Robin Hood justification
without which the overall
characterization of Dom's crew is
significantly different you can't move
forward without fuel
and no one wants to be left behind Los
Bandoleros also gives Dom and letty's
romance more time to grow before she's
thought to be killed during the First
Act of Fast and Furious it also explains
why Twinkie says Han and Dom were family
in Tokyo Drift it's more than possible
to follow Fast and Furious without
seeing Los Bandoleros that the context
provided both to the plot and the
characters undeniably gives the story
greater narrative support as for its
mention in fast X it works as a nod to
longtime fans Han and Dom basically talk
like fans themselves do marveling in
character at how drastically these
movies have changed since 2009.